welcome back to part three of South Park
the fractured but whole a very nice so
now what we're gonna do is to not
walking great I did pretty far man a lot
of different quests that we can do use
the alley to get to raisins if we all
work together everyone never understood
day-drinking you just get really
sleeping unlike outro of darkness and
lockness damn ease face find more
stations to expand your network and when
you get in trouble fast pass book beat
it by
my best friend there when I was kid with
it used to stutter I feel so bad it's
always like you wanna help but you're
not supposed to and it's just like
something you think is so easy but it's
so hard I'm the worst person ever oh
whoa you think we can do something here
I have clearly not learned the controls
shoot we just need to get up there
somehow wait I thought you said use the
alley you lying son of a snake it's this
the alley you could play with toys okay
here it is there's some more lucky bulls
here I believe we got something
promoters needed that's another it's a
side quest okay where are we on the map
let's go everybody it's a big game man
it's very big game oh look more member
berries I can't reach them okay oh yeah
I remember them so candy gets a bj
[Music]
yes I never been to a place like this or
whatever
all right yeah well that's a lot of ways
[Music]
that's his weakness really we're gonna
fight why don't we why don't you just
pay okay so I can change my thing but
I'm not gonna do it so let's just kill
these [ __ ] I'm really curious what
their attacks are he got charm per se
you wept all right all right all right
oh he attacks me
- mosquitos charmed you can use
inspection mode to learn more about the
status I think I get it l-look how fast
this put put it okay what can he do he
can hit him with this what oh it's a
weird one huh
that doesn't do that much what else you
know I don't want to heal what the hell
fine fine fine okay here we go this is
say it's gonna be tight boys it's gonna
be fire ah damn that wasn't that great
[Music]
come on Timmy you're our last hope you
don't let up god damn it oh my god oh
he's so fast he's so fast especially
keep staying oh wow oh wow and so
handsome you kill all those beakers oh
my god this is so close yes oh I missed
everything so close so close
come on come on yes hey it's really fun
oh my god I love it I was so cool got
him I overdid it switches are my
kryptonite and you must have saved me
just in time I'm forever in your debt
but Hiro what is your kryptonite
dude you can't be a superhero without
something that you're powerless thinking
what would be my weakness huh any
particular Phobos any emotional perhaps
tomato look it's okay I'm on your team
but kid you can tell me all right all
right let me see your character races
girls
chaos kids old people crab people
anything but crab people
yes I hate crab people
they're the worst people okay we have
our weakness everyone that's fun that
you get to develop your character he's
on our team now useless useless okay all
right so what's oh that's a fart our
next goal is to go to school and we
can't walk there that's strange
so we're gonna have to walk back okay we
are right at school let's unlock the
flash so awesome and let's head on to
South Park Elementary let's go in the in
the first game you came here kind of I
don't think he's gonna want to take oh
oh oh okay then what was that my
character looks so all round because of
the beard I don't go to counselors
office okay there are times when you
wear sucker in by being doing sex and
women and remember well when you do
these things too much mercy back into
that sorry the soundtrack of that movie
is the best
as your counselor you can talk to me
about anything okay
you understand you want to talk about it
see okay see I'm highly trained in them
I can tell you don't have to be afraid
okay okay new kid it's really simple
when uh when you want to talk about your
sex you simply you can start by simply
saying you know I'm a boy or a girl or
other other what is this I'm there
obviously other so you're saying you're
neither a boy nor a girl so you don't
believe you have a gender okay can you
just hang on a minute I need to call
your parents just take a second I want
to see what they saying hello this is
mr. Macky the school counselor yes I
have your child here in my office and
well your child has just let me know
that he or they identify as being
gender-neutral oh you knew that okay
well no it's done it's just I believe
everyone was under the impression that
that they were a boy okay yeah no that's
that's great that's great to know maybe
be of help from here on out on thank you
very much okay bye-bye now
okay
okay well this is a shocker new kid but
there's nothing wrong with not
identifying us as a binary gender you
can be whatever sex you want now if we
should just plate take I feel like they
wanted to write a joke there but they
don't accept you for what you are and
you're gonna have to deal with them okay
so but come see me anytime
I was hoping like I put in the extra
hour staying after school for troubled
kids like you so you want to take a
selfie then guess not
lame those lame okay
that's locked I guess we're MIT we're
making our character right now
essentially it was what happening now we
got to go meet father maxi at the church
oh this is it's so cool you can walk
everywhere I love it even though it's
quiet it's kind of nice it's um Marius
are you now its atmosphere
to the movements of the game right
there's so much load here
I can't let's just go back that's
offense and I can't walk there god
damnit there we go
we left oh my god what around here let's
welcome this fan to our town
we got to fight them because they're
against all right well let's make this
quick
yeah all right well that would feat what
is happening is its bugged out I don't
see the controllers oh my god a game is
so caliche dude
all right let's assist the ultimate of
the beam n mosquito man nice all right
let's finish him got it now finally I
did all of it nice and I'm gonna die
here
whatever oh we got you yes whatever
whatever we got it vanish hey nice I
like the challenge and it's fun really
fun you know I'm very very good at games
okay don't realize what a quest I think
it will go to a priest first mr. priest
'hey we need to buy some items and stuff
because it seems like we're really gonna
need i'll skip these guys let's go let's
go to father and here we are let's see
what featherhead I guess we're gonna
pick religion I know I'm smart
oh new child I haven't seen you before
but you come at a crucial time South
Park is sliding into moral decline
someone's stealing our cats their TP
houses
okay maybe it's not full-on armageddon
yet but we do need a hero not to make
the hard sell but do you see yourself as
a good uh chaotic evil baby every 10
understand the confusion but there comes
a time when we need to choose our path
will you find Jesus and take the
righteous path or maybe a walk the
middle way let's not talk about the
third alternative I'm hoping you're part
of the solution not the problem take the
first step by child by entering this
meditative chamber which will allow you
to confront your deepest fears face your
fears new child face your fears
why okay we're gonna fight in there what
oh it's all this complicated stuff with
me yeah take back to us
the color blue oh ah okay I am in your
imagination just a friendly Catholic
priest who would like to get to know you
a little better yeah that's right I'm
totally in your imagination - about to
give you a shoulder rub
never imagined you'd feel something like
this let me adjust the lighting in here
a bit so we can get some visuals with
them yes defeat the priest this is not
fitting new sick yes oh this is so Mis
oh my god they do a lot of damage these
enemies to use telegraphed attack
indicated by them okay we got to move
out yeah oh my god this is so disturbing
man I can't attack with that what can i
attack with I don't think I can attack
with anything No
unless I take damage of course
hey what about we play some grab-ass
I'll grab first stop I'm just gonna exit
the round actually know what the world
races know where to put it
okay all right we just got to keep
moving here that seems to be the name of
the game where we do have this attack
damage both of them stop miss me oh my
god oh he's doing the same
oh yeah he's arisen all right oh my god
stop all right let's give him flaming
damage nice I know how to do it now I
know how to do it if they wear that I
kind of want to see how they attack
connects you know
I wanna see what happens if you get kids
there it is done I guess it was just to
learn how they like dodge attacks and
stuff
we got a purity bond Wow and 1/5 of a
dollar
amazing okay all right we did it nice
we're definitely going to hell now get
out of here that's not what the Queen
spider says feel just awful about all
that tell you what a rabbi friend gave
me this macaroni [ __ ]
how about times of trouble and
tribulation use it to call upon the
prophet Moses now really luck on your
spiritual journey macho nice okay take
all and nice you see the first summon oh
yeah I remember this doing combat
exercise okay summon the mecha I can't
wait to summon a that's awesome I
thought we were gonna pick religion all
right what's the next step go to tacos
all right let's go here we go Freeman's
tacos got an heiress a de natura tamale
that was a perfect pronunciation welcome
that's right and tacos thank you thank
you very much anything is Raven well you
just let me know where I'm Gordon
Freeman you want some tacos
that's my 10 out of 10 impression of
Gordon Freeman why do I keep saying
Gordon Freeman whatever food items you
want that's his name now you're checking
your phone thereby oh okay so we can buy
oz awesome
can we take a picture first he said no
he said no
for [ __ ] sake
no okay Freeman's tacos is completely
craft your own you know what crafting is
don't you
you can combine food items into whatever
you like okay let's start with a staple
the burrito double real warm tortilla
wrapped around well any old something
here I'll give you what you need to get
started
this here's how to do you can come get
it items into whatever you like
oh go ahead see what happens if you
combine a burrito and an enchilada this
is exciting
congratulations new kid with an
enchilada and a burrito you've crafted
an injury dough it's the first time
anyone's ever done it have a few more
recipes they might just save your stupid
ass okay we got some more crafting
that's cool so can we sell some stuff
let's do some crafts let me just do some
crafting really pay Ashley oh damn we're
almost level ten we can almost do our
outfit now nice we can make butthole
gloves I'll be asleep we're gonna make
butthole gloves thank you
my character is so ugly it's amazing
[Music]
just one more thing oh one more thing
they say that some farts are so powerful
they can actually bend the fabric of
time you be careful out there just one
more thing
thank you
[Music]
okay we're doing well we're advancing
our character it would seem we can fast
travel there maybe it would seem not
okay well let's just you all together we
can make day-drinking cool all right
here's the quest you've all been waiting
for
we're delivering a Nenshi collado to
Cartman
this is this is it this is peak we've
reached peak why my sound stopped
working what is happening now oh wait
it's just quiet ma'am you're not a real
cat key to get out of here ma'am
where the heck is he I thought it was
here talk the Coons lair I'm so dumb of
course not every time really okay [ __ ]
you hmm
oh wow but you know and you can't come
take a seat it's kiss and kick me like
that you like that
all right well how's it going out there
hmm pretty good okay good talk but
listen I think you show some potential
and I'm gonna upgrade you to somebody's
sidekick or something congratulations
yeah well I think you can't see I just
maybe wanted to talk about your
superhero character a little bit um your
character sucks to be honest and I think
I'm gonna let you do a class let's pick
another ability to add what's that it
for real oh nice okay elementalist shock
and chill foes buff from friends keep
the local humidity
I think this is the one we want psychic
now we want to care we want a character
that kicks ass
a man character so we're now we're
nicely together but now we're gonna need
to change your backstory - oh my god
back again to that fateful night yes
okay you did lay awake that night but
the reason you couldn't sleep was
because you wanted to make the world a
safer place you walk to the mirror again
all right what's gonna happen in the
mirror and wondered if anyone would ever
love you and then you heard a noise but
but it was a baby crying I wonder how a
car could possibly be worse okay all
right I can dig this power surge through
your cybernetic appendages as you
focused on your prime directive protect
the baby that for some reason was
loitering in your is the random baby you
have been cybernetically enhanced with a
suite of shocking abilities you
demonstrated the first of these
abilities on your victim how the game is
clearly bugged out
uncaged your fairy day already somebody
needs to hit this little [ __ ] not a my
wife she took a swing at you but your
block absorb the damage oh hell yeah
look at that how do magnets even work
our oldest ready let's do this okay what
do we got what's gonna happen Oh
[Music]
well that did the trick more machine
than man he's my machine and man no you
beat the homemaker baby open your eyes
to take him somewhere safe and then
that's when the unthinkable happened
no you saw your dad [ __ ] your mom
oh my god then on you had to live with
the fact because you were busy helping a
baby stop your mama being
that's heavy man I'm really sorry I know
you probably wanted to know why why your
dad [ __ ] your mom
those are answers you'll have to find
for yourself what's happening what have
they done now we're coming [ __ ] app well
new kid looks like you might be needing
those newfound powers follow me
what what oh okay it would be great if
you didn't glitch out select the power
is up or sorry okay we have four slots
so we don't we only get to pick a couple
of them alright so I'm not really too
much of a fan of these because they're
all kind of the same so I would rather
have there okay we did it
let's get out of here
[Music]
no time to waste but Oh
this way my home the bus trap
damn he's fast for a fat kid freedom
pounds he's on the move
the confrontation is brewing yes this
way keep going towards the bus stop man
escort missions are the worst
Jr's thank you thank you card men so
self-aware okay my controller keeps
buzzing man what is happening
Ben Ben Ben Ben we were supposed to be a
duo remember tweek yeah I remember
so when I walked out of [ __ ] afraid you
should've walked out with me I like
coded fret because you had your own
movies thank god you're here
they're really going at it so for Craig
had to have lilies before one your
twinkles introduced and they no sets
otherwise y'all well they don't set
because you're a traitor tweek and now
you're with a group of super traitors
this was started by you by people who
thought there should be preferential
treatment to certain heroes we are the
ones who walked out of the [ __ ]
franchise mysterion your franchise is
going nowhere
face the truth you guys are kind of
douche eyes
he just called us douchebags in my mind
he can't fight you son of a [ __ ] no ha
ha
[Music]
oh he's Timmy I'm so stupid sorry sorry
I'm so sorry I forgot some names Kami's
I don't want to start with nice they're
shocked let's take things back babe
it's back boy
alright self Tumut time
I never get sick assay in this one it's
beautiful it's discard impure
there's a get better than this yeah oh
my god it makes it quick there it is
Donna excellent thank you I need to fix
it-it's so annoying I can't see I guess
I have to restart the game or something
like that hey wait what about oh come on
yeah what about [ __ ] what happened Timmy
got away yes he completely made to maya
angelou a killer okay no seriously you
guys you [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of my
brains huh I grabbed him we fought for a
little bit but it's his missile powers
are too strong
so we did all that for nothing not quite
I got to me cellphone let's get this
back to base super crate can analyze it
super Craig that's that's the skill
hello is this little superhero who is
getting all the followers on Instagram
that's me you mean CUDA grants fastest
kid in town awesome
[Music]
see you new kid call on me whenever you
want to get somewhere I'm got it so
annoying yeah call on me whenever you
wanna get too much I don't
eminent looking guys went out of style
in the 80s but the new kids pulling it
up all right let's talk to Cooney Wow
there you are but huh
all right let's get to work why isn't
you kid in my space I'm busy here we go
when have you found super Craig Timmy's
load has a bunch of notes in it
something about a girl who has
information about all the criminal
activity in town what Kara it just says
spied the girl with the dick tattoo
what girl in town has a dick tattoo I
don't know mosquito but the freedom pals
must think she's the key to finding the
missing cat if the freedom house find
her before we do they'll get the hundred
dollar reward we cannot let that happen
we have to stop the freedom pals from
having a sweet franchise at all costs
then we have to find the girl with that
tattoo tonight that's Hazzard right we
all have to sneak out of our houses
tonight search the entire town what do
you say new kid you up for it of course
yes yeah who let this guy join us anyway
go easy on him you guys he's had a tough
night ha ha ha ha ha when he was 6 years
old
his dead [ __ ] his man
I'm sorry friend but it's time they
learned to you're a tragic backstory but
hoe doesn't trust anyone because his dad
[ __ ] his mom and he couldn't do
anything to study that doesn't make any
sense I know how could the person you
trust do that to the only other person
you love Carbon everyone's dad [ __ ] to
everyone's mom hey that's how it works
stupid our dad's [ __ ] our mom's right
so does that mean your dad [ __ ] your
mom cam yeah yes my dad [ __ ] my mom
that's why I'm here
don't steal his backstory dude that's
not stupid every human alive on earth
had a dad who [ __ ] their mom it's not
this is not what's important right now
that's right that's right we do need you
finds a lady with the big day - lets go
- Prince he's such a [ __ ] okay calm
down
I'm afraid you'll have to deal with that
kind of bigger to your whole life but
people don't understand they lash out
knowing Colette you'd be a sidekick
tonight to one of the [ __ ] friends go
home and sneak out after your parents
are asleep I'll fill you in later okay
change of costume yes
[Music]
yes
let's change it
oh yeah okay let's take a break here and
thank you guys for leaving and like I
really appreciate it thank you for all
the comments support I love seeing it it
means some lie and I'll see you tomorrow
with another video
brofist squint